other character are you okay yeah i  don't think the aliens are coming back  anytime soon how do you know well the  previous scene was shot on imax because  it was a big action scene now that the  bars are back on the screen wait you can  see those two i can tell we're being  shot in 35 millimeter which is easier  and cheaper to shoot with huh yeah  nothing big is going to happen during a  widescreen scene but doesn't that  release some of the tension making  audiences at least subtly aware of when  an action set piece is going to occur  probably  but christopher nolan does it so we're  just all okay with it now oh i mean  disney pixar's lightyear did it and  that's an animated movie so it's kind of  becoming part of film grammar these days  i don't know how i feel about that hold  on  we're going back into an imax scene [ __ ]  [ __ ] [ __ ] no watch out